[Music]
alright believe nation we're in the car
with the kids there's a street that has
all sorts of Santa Clauses where
everybody bought the same Santa Claus
from the same store so we're going to
film it as we drive by we have Nina we
have Hayden and we have his two cousins
Jeffrey and Katherine what's up guys you
want to see some Santa Claus ok let's go
see some Santa Claus there's a very
Santa Claus hello Santa what's up mister
that's a good one apparently one person
bought it one year and then all the
neighbors decided they would buy it too
so that's a start let's keep going ha i
see one I see what Lucy no it's a street
full of Santa I see more Santa Claus
what do you guys want to say here comes
bored Santa who comes for Santa it's
that one he's waving from the corner I
think that last Santa Claus was my
favorite what do you think guys oh I see
more I see more how many have we seen so
far like three more than three or less
more than three more Santa Claus give me
that dad 10 11 I think it's more than
that look at all these Santa Claus what
do you think Nina
mean it's too busy focusing oh look at
the shriveled up Santa you're gonna get
the shriveled up Santa Claus look kisi
cabled up Santa oh you lost it there
that Santa Claus lost is there let's get
going let's find some more serious oh
look all the same as a fellow for poor
Santa Claus for Santa Claus all right
we're almost done welcome the Kringle
would that science had welcome to
Kringle would this street is named
Englewood and so I guess I call the
Kringle wood up there Kris Kringle Santa
Claus that's the last and applause it's
it all right well thank you guys for
joining us in Kringle would okay what's
your message guys what do you want to
say nice Merry Christmas thank you guys
for watching we believe in you we hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
guys I gotta drive we'll see you soon
have a great 2017